psychological walls or barriers like
it blows my mind and i'm jealous of it
but i'm also like freaked by it but
that's why watching this i feel like
[ __ ] the flat screen this is
the best netflix show i've ever seen
right now yeah yeah yeah but you know
we're not together anymore
oh
yeah we're not
oh
sorry yeah
so why can't we can we do it now or
do you can do what expose ourselves yeah
yeah no you you are i mean holy [ __ ]
yeah i'm sorry but i think that maybe
that was the root of some of our
problems do you think
is it that we we let the world he gave
too much i think of our relationship to
the world oh yeah and then um
because then it's not yours anymore
intimacy
is like
it's like a little ball of fire that
burns inside you and
it's like you ever see those candles
that you can close the and they're
inside like you put a candle in a thing
and close it and it's glowing yeah
that's intimacy but when you open that
door and everything just flows out to
the world but the candle still burning
yeah but it you're the heat's
dissipating and the light's dissipating
and it's it's not your little warm
little burning ember anymore and it's
it's again i'm not saying it's bad to
share it to the world but you're right i
think there's a cost to it but then i
would throw back at you please is there
a cost to not opening up to the world
it's that's that's the thing about the
human mechanism right you just
we're never going to know the answers to
these things but i like your the way you
do it where it's like you are open but
certain things are sacred yeah and um i
wish i had learned that lesson a little
bit sooner because i think we you can
still be relatively open and giving of
yourself without letting a hundred of
your 100
of your life be up for consumption yeah
because there's two schools that thought
one
you're creating fodder for people right
yeah you've got all these people that
are really
guarded and they're using your openness
as fodder just as
entertainment or
as a spectacle
and then the other thing is if you kind
of give too much of yourself away then
what do you have to give each other
anymore that's ex you know
that's exactly
oh
you're right
you [ __ ] we did it we should have done
it
we did it we [ __ ] it up oh no i'm not
sure no you're right oh you [ __ ] it up
no hey hey arla
marlin okay
i wouldn't change it for the world baby
that's what i was just gonna say you
can't it's it
you can't change the program
listen i am who i am yeah and um
i use podcasting to vent
it's gotten me in trouble you know me
i've i've said enemies of mine on air
that are in show business and now
they're blocking me on instagram you
know what i mean i use it as a way of
venting
and and expressing my frustrations but
you i beg of you whoever you um see next
in a serious way in a serious
relationship i beg of you not to i've
never
again you can't say that you're my last
one you're my last definitely you're
saying that now that's right you're the
last chapter of that book but in the
beginning when you um when i wasn't even
podcasting yet you would give a lot of
information about me like that was that
that never gave you permission to talk
about right okay i'm sorry the abortion
no more than just that like the color of
my [ __ ] and things like that i am sorry
it's a beautiful color um
you can't find that color in the crayon
box are you sure
it's a beautiful color i got to know
what color it is it's like a magenta-ish
peach oh wow that's like a caribbean
sunset
have you ever had a flamingo fly across
your
front
sometimes i do notice that yeah i just
want to blow a conch shell and watch you
dance
[Laughter]
yeah yeah it's beautiful yeah is that
yeah it's a vacation
when i look at it it's like i feel
relaxed i can hear birds chirping oh
yeah i mean they can't just go club med
sex right yeah dude but you're right
i did things
and i'm never gonna do that again but
then i did the same thing like um as
soon as i
he was like it's just be free klyla be
free so then i bought into it and then i
started to
mimic exactly how he was which is well
[ __ ] it i might as well now that it's
out there i'm just gonna
you know put it all out there too
and
uh but what was the what was the the
drawback to it what was the the effect
that you didn't like exactly like you
said you give it all away to other
people what is left for each other
like oh so they use information that you
set at one point because everyone can go
back and then they use it against you
right and it's like
um
yeah there's certain things that are
like personal
right that i don't want to people to use
but they're they are using these
personal things that i have real deep
feelings
about
against me and making fun of me about it
and it hurts even more because it's like
number one i'm the one that put it out
there and it's also when it's personal
like that it just hurts more people can
go
online i don't think you're funny that's
just your opinion
right but when they're people people are
using like personal things that i have
said about our past or this and that
that hurts you know i mean so it's like
but that's also our fault that's what
i'm saying that's why
you i honest i honestly believe
i'm never gonna see anybody else again i
really do i honestly you believe that
harlan no i thank you here's why why
because you don't have any control over
that thank you oh i do yeah no you don't
yeah wait wait wait wait wait i'll tell
you why right now that's what i'm gonna
do
here's why bro safiosh okay
[Music]
better help now a word from our sponsor
better help you guys yeah i talked about
betterhelp all the time it's my favorite
thing in the whole world you guys